من القاهره تنضم لنا عبر الهاتف الفنانه
لقاء الخميسي لقائي يسعد صباحك شكرا على
تواجدك معنا في صباح العربيه اهلا بك صباح
الخير اهلا بك حبيبتي اهلا بك اهلا بك
تصريحات ملفته جدا الا اما ادب الفعليه
لقاء تعتقدين ان الفنان بات هدفا مستباحا
للجمهور الانتقاده
الاول
احنا بقى لنا سنين بالوضع ده يعني انا بس
عايزه يعني اقول الاول
احنا كنا متطورين انها هتبقى شيء مفيد
من دول مختلفه للتبادل الثقافات
لحريه الراي واحترام الاخر الواضح انها
قلبت بشكل مؤذي جدا لناس كثير قوي لدرجه
انه في ناس بتنتحر وفي ناس
بتكتئب وفي ناس بتتعالج بسبب التنمر اللي
على السوشيال ميديا همم
تفضلي في ناس بتقول انه انتم قررت تكونوا
تحت الاضواء بالتالي يجب عليكم انه تتقبل
النقد وان كان جارح فهناك رؤساء دول تتعرض
للنقت من قبل البعض ليلا النهار رامز سواء
على السوشيال ميديا او عبر وسائل الاعلام
تمام لا هو انا ممكن اعتقد حضرتك او حضرتك
تنقليني ولكن كل الحريه لكن في حدود
الانتقاد في حدود للحوار في حدود لان انت
ما تدخليش في عيلتي وما تدخليش في عرضي
وما تشتميش وما تقرريش حاجات انت ما
تعرفيهاش احنا دلوقتي بنحاكم الرؤساء على
حسب النتائج اللي النتائج اللي بيقدموها
تمام واوراقهم كلها مفتوحه لكن انت تعرف
عندي ايه في بيتي انت تعرف علاقتي بقى عن
عامله ازاي مع اهلي بتعرف تفاصيل حياتي
انا بامر بايه فكره ان انت تقول الوقت
شايف الممثل او الفنان او المطرب انه بي-
بي- بيرمي فلوس على الارض لانه مش حاسس
بحاجه انه ما عندوش مشاكل الكلام ده مش
طبيعي الكلام ده مش طبيعي يعني كل بني ادم
عنده مشاكله اللي مش المفروض ان هو يجهلها
للمجتمع همم
لقاء زمان كان الفنان ينتقد من قبل نقاط
محترفين او من قبل الصحافه الصفراء اليوم
الى اي مدى مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كسرت
هذا الحاجز بين الفنان وجمهوره حضرتك
الصحافه نفسها هي هي اللي بتخلي
الجمهور ينتقد بالطريقه دي هي اللي
بتستفزه هي اللي بتقتطع يعني جمل معينه من
الحوارات تدل على معاني الناس تخليها
تبتدي بقى تشتمه وتنين وكده فالصحافه
بتشجع الناس على ده الصح حصل دلوقتي يهمها
انها تبقى شويه لان انت فاهمه الامور
دلوقت نائمه في اوضاع كثير جدا عندنا
فتبتدي بقى او الصحافه في العالم كله هي
اللي بتواجه الجمهور ليه ذباب الفنيه
فوق خيالك يعني
يبتدوا تنمروا على اطفال مثلا اطفال
فنانين يبتدوا يتنمروا على على الاهالي طب
وعلاقتها ايه علاقه امينه ايه بالموضوع
انت فاهمني ايه علاقتهم بالموضوع
تنتقد انتقد فني انتقد تمثيلي انتقد ادوار
لكن لا تنتقدني كاسان في كمان طيار يقول
اذا لم يكن هناك نقد للفنان للممثل راح
تضيع الطاسه زي ما بيقولوا يعني بالعاميه
يفقد الفن الراقي هيبته هو معه يصبح كل
واحد يسمي حاله فنان كل واحد يسمي حاله
ممثل زي ما كل واحد يسمي حاله اعلامي
تمام تمام هو ده ماشي يا اما انا باقول
لحضرتك هو ممكن ينتقدني في دور ينتقدني في
عمل فني لينتقد ادائي ينتقد مصداقيتي لكن
هو ما لوش الحق ينتقد حياتي الشخصيه ما
لهوش الحق يتنمر علي انسانيه لانه انا في
الاخر انسان ولياه حقوق
اذا تجاوز النقد من قبل الجمهور من النقد
البناء الى الشخصنه النقد يعني الى
التجريح الى الاهانه لشخص الفنان ما هي
حدود رد الفنان انت كيف تردين اللقاء بصي
انا ساعات باسكت كثير جدا جدا وبعد كده
بصراحه ما بقاش قادره خالص لاني باحس انه
في ناس كثير بيجيء لها اكتئاب من اصدقائي
وكثير منهم وفي ناس ممكن تتعرض ان هي مثلا
تدخل المصحات نفسيه ليه كل ده علشان ايه
فبصراحه بارد انا ما باسيبش احد يعني يعني
سيبيه مره اثنين ثلاثه وخلاص بقى بارد
عشان اليوم برده المعلومه ما بتوصلش
بسهوله على فكره
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر على ما دخلتك معنا
من القاهره كانت معنا عبر الهاتف فنانه
لقاء الخميس شكرا لك
[موسيقى]